about first year is working as junior
consultant mckinsey as bwl prepared
when going into meetings soul everything
always carroll you attacked consultant
der forst these presenters you can just
plug maybe never before here
a laptop anymore just click to
progress des sorrows very important des
wlan adapters north
projectors therefore require red from
connectors max or small location will
always be able to connect projectors in
the meeting with this but least once
more portable audio conferencing spiders
justice or the youth leaders meeting
rooms coverage if the protect to
partner sales jonas possibility as
junior  consultant to make sure as
hell knows how strings and men preformatted for the mac